erzähle mir einen Witz warum haben die
Tomaten Angst vor der gewürzlachau
welche Paprika sind
[Gelächter]
erzähle mir einen Witz warum haben Bäume
keine Freunde weil sie immer auf Ihre
Wünsche anschauen
okay eine Sache kann er nicht Witze
erzählen Chatbot GPT ist die künstliche
Intelligenz über die gerade alle
sprechen
Supercomputer der mit all dem Wissen aus
dem Internet gefüttert wurde und in
Zukunft die meisten geistigen Jobs
wegnehmen würde sagen zumindest einige
Leute aber bevor diese dunkle Zukunft
auch uns einfach lustiges damit und
fragen ob sie etwas ganz Neues erfinden
kann und in meinem Fall will ich ein
ganz neues Tortenrezept was ist noch nie
gab kannst du ein Rezept für eine Torte
erfinden die es noch nie gab
wie wäre es mit einer Schokoladen
Erdnussbutter Banane Torte
südated 2000 Telefone
das ist ein Rezept das muss ich jetzt
aber einmal raus und Schokolade
Erdnussbutter Banane Torte naja eine
Schoko Erdnuss Torte mit Banane
gibt's schon meine Ewigkeit später sei
es gibt die Geschmäcker aber diese Torte
ist komplett neu ich habe das noch nie
so gemacht und ich finde die Idee
eigentlich mega geil das ist unser
Rezept ich frage mich nur woher holt
sich Chatbot diese Ideen also gibt es
einen gibt es eine Quelle wie wie
gut Schokoladen Erdnussbutter Bananen
Torte danke das klingt lecker
ich hoffe es schmeckt Direktor und deine
Freundin und Familie hütt wenn du frei
hast stehe ich direkt gerne zur
Verfügung so nett ja let's go für den
Namen gibt es einen abzugspunkt
Schokoladen Erdnussbutter bananen-torte
hätte man sich da nicht was kreativeres
ausdenken können so erdbar schokibato
wir machen eine klassische
also wir machen einen klassische
sugarbatoah dass ich die fetteste Taube
aller Zeiten gesetzt oh gut ich meine
Zutaten Zubereitung alles ist hier ganz
genau erklärt ich habe keine Ahnung
woher Chatbot das hat also wenn man an
die Witze denkt sie gemacht hat okay
dann ja sie findet das selbst kommen wir
aber zur Zubereitung auf 180 Grad ofen
auf 180 Grad vor hätten das kriege ich
hin ich mache jetzt mal Umluft 180 Grad
Umluft klingt richtig eine Runde Kirche
Form einfetten und mit mehr ausschrauben
sorry ich habe das noch nie gemacht
gefettet und damit Mehl ausgestäubt ich
weiß nicht ob es eine Technik ist die
man sonst macht aber soweit so gut
zweitens in einer Schüssel Melker
Kakaopulver Backpulver und Natrium
vermissten drittens in einer anderen
wirklich nichts ich habe einen Schritt
übersprungen
ich hätte die feuchten Zutaten in einer
anderen Schüssel vermischen müssen naja
dafür bekommt ihr hier meine Eier auf
mach skills
immer perfekt fahren die Extrakt
verrühren viertens die vierte südtarte
schatue den Drucker südarte geben und
tritt für mich change Chatbot toller
Teig so soll doch Kuchenteig Aussehen 15
in die vorbereitete Küche Form geben und
ca 30 Minuten Becken oder Beach ein
sandstocher sauber herauskommt wird
ziemlich flach aber jetzt kommt der
erstmal in den Ofen ja in der
Zwischenzeit die Erdnussbutter und
Bananen in einer Schüssel
natürlich nicht wie dolles vermischt
werden muss reicht das oder sollen wir
eine gleichmäßig pürierte Masse haben
boah das sieht aber schon lecker aus
muss ich sagen
[Musik]
es sieht vielleicht hätte ich die
Bananen noch mehr zermatschen können
aber es würde genauso aussehen das ist
meine Torte danke Chatbot ich werde sie
jetzt mal abkühlen lassen und dann
machen wir den test test diese Torte ich
eine perfekte Kombination aus Schokolade
und Erdnussbutter mit einer bananenhaut
und eine leckere Textstelle jetzt sieht
es mittlerweile ein bisschen aus wie
Karamell ich vermute dass die Banane
einfach nachgedunkelt ist so wie wenn
eine Banane dunkel wird wenn man sie
irgendwo liegen lässt es sieht echt aus
wie Karamell Moment
so als angeschnittenes Stück sieht das
optisch schon viel besser aus und unsere
Bananen Erdnussbutter Mischung sieht aus
wie Karamell und nun stellen wir uns
wieder der allerwichtigsten Frage wie
schmeckt eine Torte erfunden von Chatbot
GPT einer künstlichen Intelligenz
tschüss
[Musik]
also der Kuchen schmeckt nicht besonders
schokoladig
aber doch der Kuchenteig schmeckt
perfekt eigentlich für eine Torte also
wenn man da noch viel Creme Früchte
Marzipan was weiß ich da alles noch oben
drauf macht durch diese dünne Bananen
Erdnussbutter Schicht passiert da halt
geschmacklich nicht so viel ich würde
gerne Kuchen nennen Torte aber man kann
es essen wenn er nur wenn man mit Banane
backt wird es oft wie so ein Pamela reif
Zero sugar Rezept und hier ist sehr viel
Zucker drin deswegen bin ich ein
bisschen verwirrt
ich weiß es nicht dreieinhalb von fünf
Punkten also die Creme da oben drauf die
ist irgendwie genial ich finde nicht
dass es sehr stark nach Erdnussbutter
schmeckt eher nach Banane aber es ist so
eine leichte gute Creme das dürfte ich
nicht so eine dicke Scheibe sein das
müsste eine schöne dünne Scheibe sein
und dazwischen müsste Creme sein das
wäre vielleicht ein guter Muffin das ist
okay es ist jetzt kein Meisterwerk
schreibt gerne in die Kommentare welches
Rezept soll Chatbot GPT noch für mich
erfinden und wir sehen uns dann das
nächste Mal wieder vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und für eure Zeit bis dann